[MUSIC]
All strategic leaders face
complexity in
their competitive environments.
What you see is an enormous variety
of potentially disruptive processes
going on that really exacerbate
the challenges that leaders face.
[MUSIC] What leaders need to do is
have a set of skills for
diagnosing the challenges
that they're tackling.
And also then being able to
translate that into an action plan.
>> What I'd like to do is to
get out how my business unit can
contribute to my company's strategy
and align with my
company's long-term goals.
>> The main focus of this
program is on the issue of
what we call alignment.
How do I align my strategy to my
competitive environment?
And how do I align my
organizational design to the
strategy that I'm trying to pursue?
>> What is the right leadership?
And what works and
what doesn't work?
>> Great organizations
are well-aligned organizations.
We really bring together faculty
who have devoted their careers to
understanding the kinds of
challenges that leaders face.
>> These are the guys that wrote
the cases and we're in the room
with the people who worked in
the companies so it's fantastic.
>> Their innovation in the world
right now is centered
out of Silicon Valley and
I see Stanford as a hub for that.
>> One of the great things about
EPSO is the incredible diversity
of participants, participants
from all over the world from all
different kinds of organizations.
So much of the benefit of
the program comes from the lessons
that you learn from people in
different contexts.
Successful leadership is
not about cookie-cutter solutions.
We really want to take you away
from just feeding your standard,
here's what all the best
companies do, to saying
let's give you the ability to
build your own solution set.
>> Each person came with different
perspectives.
>> The information on this program
will help me become a better
leader.
>> Was a really well-rounded global
experience I will
treasure it the rest of my life.
[MUSIC]